hello and welcome to this episode of the
future verse brought to you by
Intelligence Squared and Y tree I'm
Kamal Ahmed now ytree was founded in
2017 to give its clients the
transparency efficiency and meaning to
fully understand their financial lives
as they are and as they could be
today we're turning to our latest theme
in the future verse risk in our previous
episodes we explored Financial Risk in
all its forms with white trees Johnny
hemple and Nick Humphries senior partner
at HG capital and we delved into the ups
and downs of Entrepreneurship and
running your own business with Michael
Welch Obe
but today we're concluding this
mini-series by examining risk very
literally
and this one is a real pleasure for me
because we are bringing together two
leaders in their field but also two
people I am fortunate to know and they
have much to reveal about the world of
risk taken for the most noble of
purposes
Christina Lam is one of Britain's
leading foreign correspondents and a
best-selling author she has reported
from most of the world's hot spots
beginning with Afghanistan where she
covered the mujah had been fighting the
Soviet Union when she was just 22.
she is currently Chief foreign
correspondent at the Sunday Times and
her latest book is our bodies their
Battlefield what war does to women
Simon Reeve is an adventurer and
best-selling author and TV presenter who
has traveled to more than
120 countries making multiple
award-winning TV series for the BBC
described as British television's most
adventurous traveler he has spent nearly
two decades traveling the world
he's dodged bullets on the front line
he's hunted with the Bushmen of the
Kalahari and been detained for spying by
the KGB
he started his career as a post boy at
the Sunday Times
uh I think it's safe to say that both
our guests can speak with authority on
risk and we're delighted to have brought
them both together Simon Christina
welcome to the podcast now
Simon I'm going to start with you first
I think you and Christina may have met
before just take us through that just
kick us off
oh so I was as you said I was a post boy
on the Sunday Times that's how I started
um I didn't have the most illustrious
education
um uh before becoming an adult I dropped
out of school uh when I was uh 17 16 17
I was on the Dole for a bit and then I
got a job
um working at the Sunday time sorting
the post
and over a couple of years I graduated
um from being there at half five in the
morning
um sorting the mail to being I think a
junior Cub or Junior home news
researcher or something like that and
then a researcher brackets home news and
then that sort of gentle climb upper a
low ladder
um and I remember you know obviously
sorting the post for Christina
um although it's possible that's just a
yarn that I've invented in my head
because Christina may have joined a
little bit later I'm just wondering why
I never seemed to get anything yeah
ah all those Scoops Christina that got
lost in the post room you could have won
even more Awards Christina than you have
done
Christina gives you a little bit of um
the opening I mean the amazing journey
she went on from a very very young age I
know we'll get to this a bit more but
just tell us just to give us a little
potted history of the career so actually
I mean I never set out to be a war
correspondent um I really wanted to be a
novelist
um and so I had this idea of going
abroad and working as a journalist for a
while to have some adventures and then
go and rent a Garrett somewhere and
write my great novel but I started off
as you said at the beginning in
Afghanistan and that was really by
accident because I got invited to a
wedding in Pakistan and it wasn't an
ordinary wedding it was Benazir Buddha's
wedding I had interviewed her in England
when she was here in Exile and I was an
intern for the financial times just
starting out and she was very nice to me
and the day that I interviewed her she
just announced her engagement as if that
is the diary so her flat was full of
bouquets of flowers
so it may be because of that I don't
know but some months later I was then
working in Birmingham as a trainee
reporter for Central TV most Junior
person in The Newsroom and I came home
one day and there was this most
beautiful God inscribed invitation to a
wedding and it was Venezia's wedding in
Pakistan so of course I went and it was
the first time I'd ever been to Pakistan
it was an amazing introduction to the
country because her wedding was so
colorful and so many interesting people
were there and it went on for a week and
every evening after all this sort of
ceremonial events there were Gatherings
with her political colleagues to talk
about how to topple Pakistan's military
dictator General Zia so it was
absolutely fascinated these people some
of them were not much older than me and
they'd been arrested to gas tortured for
trainspring democracy to their country
and at that point the most dangerous
thing I'd ever done was to find my way
home late at night from Central London
after a gig
um when the trains had stopped so it was
really intrigued so I came back and
couldn't really imagine covering local
news in Birmingham anymore and so I gave
it my notice and told everybody I was
going to live in Pakistan
but when I went to talk to foreign
editors about freelancing from Pakistan
nobody was interested they always said
that General Zia had been there for 11
years nothing was going to change and
then a couple of them said we are
interested in Afghanistan because at
that point it was under Soviet
occupation
um so I said okay I'll go and cover that
so I went to live in Bashar on the
border with Pakistan Afghanistan and
started traveling with the Afghan
madridi into Afghanistan and fell in
love with it
what's really fascinating hearing both
of you speak is how
you don't sort of decide to take risk
but that it can come to you and become
part of your life that notion that
the journey into situations where you
have to start managing risk and come
from so many different places and just
hearing your two stories about how you
started your careers I think really
reveals that Christina how do you
gear change if I could put it like that
between
Ukraine Afghanistan how do you gear
change back into what might be described
as ordinary life
that's the hardest thing of my job I
think it's
to come back I think that maybe
the most jarring time of that was in
2006 I was with the
um three parachute regiment in helmands
in Afghanistan and we were ambushed and
completely surrounded for hours running
through these muddy fields we were
really really lucky to get out and one
of the things that kept me going and
running in this sort of 45 Centigrade
heat with no water with all this firing
going on
was knowing that it was my son's
birthday at the end of the week and it
was his uh seventh birthday and that I
had promised to be back to host a
football party in a park in Southwest
London
um and so I did get back and it was so
strange because literally I arrived at
Heathrow on the Sunday and went straight
to Tesco's to buy like bread and ham and
then went to the park to have this party
and I was absolutely covered still in
thorns and bruises from jumping in and
out of these muddy ditches to try not to
be sure
um at my story about it was on the front
page of the Sunday Times and and yeah I
was in this party with all these six and
seven year olds in this park and that
really felt very very odd indeed Simon
did it change your attitude to the work
you do or your attitude to risk in the
work you do when you became a father
not immediately
um the first place I went to after my
son Jake was born
uh within a couple of weeks after he was
born actually was uh or a month or so
was the Mogadishu
and in Somalia and it was a it was a
tricky time there
um but that was I knew that was part of
the deal as it were
um I was making a series where I was
traveling around the Indian Ocean
um it had been my idea
um the way the the trips had just
ended up being planned out like that was
it meant that I was going after Jake was
born it wasn't to make a point or
anything
um and I think as he grew and became has
become more of a
um a grown-up little man which happens
as you'll know surprisingly quickly
um then I suppose I felt a little bit
more conscious of his existence and my
responsibility to balance providing for
him with with not taking unnecessary
crazy risks that aren't mitigated by by
reward I suppose so everything I do I've
got to feel that it's Justified
um I feel like I've got to be able to
look him in the eye and say this is why
I did it
um I don't want him to uh live his life
without a father
um definitely definitely not and I had a
partner earlier in life who had suffered
the catastrophic loss of her
father in the sort of circumstances
we're talking about and I know and I
knew how it always
not affected her for a a period or a
decade or anything but would do for
always so I'm very conscious of that
um this is my job this is what I do I
feel there's some justification for it I
feel I can
um say to him look I'm not there on a
jolly I'm there to film this or film
that and explain it and I think that's
the real
um learning for me that whereas I would
have slightly more not blindly but
perhaps with slightly more cavalierly
um started on projects and gone to
strange places now I need to have a
clear understanding in my own head just
a slightly clearer so it's not it's not
a revolutionary thought it's more of a
slight Evolution and and a calming as
you as you grow mature and get a bit
older Christina similar question does
does becoming has becoming apparent
changed your attitude to your appetite
for risk and how you manage it
yes of course because you're responsible
for somebody else I think in my case I
mean I've always covered conflict like
from when I was starting out so
um
and when I look back actually the things
I did when I was 22 I mean I think then
you think you're indestructible and you
know you nothing will happen to you uh
although actually the job has got more
dangerous but what happened with me is
my son was actually born in 1999 and so
I did think about changing what I was
doing and I took a sabbatical in 2001 to
actually because I also write books I
took a sabbatical to work on a book and
uh
my husband's Portuguese and so I was
going to write in the book in Portugal
we literally arrived in Portugal on the
11th of September 2001.
um actually we arrived on the 10th 11th
morning was my first morning that I was
planning to start working on this book
and then I got a phone call and we
didn't even have a TV where we were so
we had to go to a local chicken
restaurant and we watched the 911
attacks so of course Mike sabbatical got
canceled from my paper I think Christina
hearing from both of you it is that
notion of a lot of this is driven by a
personal desire and engagement in as I
said at the beginning of the podcast it
is something
that has a nobility about it about
explaining exploring and holding to
account around these vitally important
issues which I think is something to do
with the DNA of being a journalist or a
content creator and a creative Simon
when you're thinking about risk did were
you always somebody who in your 20s did
you imagine yourself to be a risk taker
is there such a thing or was it a
different motivation
I think there is such a thing yes I
think I've certainly met people over the
years who
um take risks uh because they need to
feel that that makes them alive and I
would
I would say that yes I I take some risks
but I don't really take it for the sake
of the risk I take it for the reward
um and the reward has got to be quite
clear for me whether that's
uh the content we're creating or whether
it's the article the book The whatever
or to be honest you know to to provide
for my family I don't do
I don't take risks I would say for
personal Joy or personal gain
um in that sort of emotional sense it's
got to be more practical or or to a
certain degree
moral or financial almost was I always
yeah I probably was a bit as a lad
um so when I was in my early teens I was
um I was pretty naughty
um when you talk about risk I think
being in my little BMX gang
um cycling
no hands down Acton High Street
um with my brother on the back of the
bike weaving in and out of cars and and
causing trouble really I mean that's
that's that strikes me as
um Cavalieri risky and stupid but I I
had I mean I had by my time in my
mid-teens I I had trouble getting out of
bed I wasn't
um I was wasn't about taking risks it
was about being able to get up in the
morning I was in a complete state of
dark depression
um and then for me taking a risk was
getting out of bed and putting one step
in front of the other and going to the
news agent getting a paper and going
through the job ads and that felt
um risky and and scary that and and I
think those two elements are quite
important together so that that was my
that was me starting with risk in many
ways as a as a young adult and then when
I started working as I said I started
working as a post boy but opportunities
um very quickly came my way and I was I
was somebody who said yes a lot
um that didn't necessarily come
naturally to me but I was Keen to have a
chance I was Keen to sense that a door
was opening a crack and then stepping
through it and although I was often
terrified of what I was doing I started
working on uh some investigations when I
was at the paper I started one of my big
breaks was tracking down
these two South African Neo-Nazi
terrorists who are on the run in the UK
and going to find them at um in Boston
first thinking it was Boston in the
states of course and worrying I didn't
have a passport and then discovering it
was Boston in Lincolnshire and having to
retrieve them from this little market
town and that was that was a scary and
risky Endeavor that
um I could have said no to but once
you've said yes once you've sort of
maybe I'm just very pliable once you've
said yes to something then you've got to
I feel I've got to deliver on that so
whether it's okay I've agreed I'm gonna
go and get these terrorists I better go
and find them or whether it's I'm going
to travel around the Indian Ocean so of
course part of that idea is to go to
Bangladesh it's to see the problems of
Somalia as well as the glory of
Mozambique and and Madagascar so once
I've committed I tend to stick with
things but it can just sometimes be that
little saying yes that gets you into a
situation you hadn't quite expected or
prepared for and I wouldn't say I I
wouldn't personally say I am and now
actual risk taker but I've come to be
fairly comfortable with taking risks I
wrote a book on uh Al-Qaeda it became a
book about Al Qaeda in the 1990s after
the first attack on the World Trade
Center and that probably was my real
introduction to a proper serious risk
and in many ways I didn't think I've
ever really taken quite as many risks as
I did while I was on my own without a
safety net without anyone to say are you
sure
um and so I took a few risks then that I
perhaps now regret Christina take us
through similar Journey for you
obviously as you mentioned at the
beginning and we we mentioned that the
outset of this uh this uh podcast
Afghanistan at 22 tell us a bit a about
your experience of doing that the
amazing things you actually went through
when you arrived and then and then let's
broaden out into how has the
conversation changed in our industry and
frankly I'm sure in many others when I
started out of course there was none of
this um and I just went off on my own
and there was no mobile phones there was
no satellite phones in Afghanistan where
I was going there were no phones and so
I would go off for weeks and nobody knew
where I was and I I used to worry a bit
about my mum getting worried so I'd
leave postcards with friends to post to
her while I was away so that she
wouldn't realize that I'd disappeared
somewhere but actually the post was so
bad from Pakistan I'm not sure it really
they arrived until I came back anyway so
actually I mean of course weren't many
women doing this job then although there
wasn't something I particularly thought
about until later on
um and so it was often quite hard to
persuade the Afghan regarding to take me
because they'd say you know like women
don't go to war
um but I did persuade this group at one
point to take me on the backs of their
motorbikes to Kandahar and spent three
weeks traveling around cam the highway
these guys who ended up becoming the
Taliban actually
but then when the Russians poured out
there was a lot of pressure on The
Afghan madridines to capture a city to
show that they could actually control
some area and the nearest city to
Pakistan was jalalabad so they were
really many of them didn't want to do
this because they knew that they would
be very high casualties if they tried to
take a city so they went in and Pakistan
intelligence isi which was kind of
controlling everything closed the border
to stop people going in because they
didn't want journalists to see what was
happening so everybody all the
journalists they were trying to find a
way in and eventually an Afghan friend
said to me we've got these ambulances
going in so we could hide you in the
ambulance so I said great so I hid under
the floor of the ambulance they had all
these sort of blankets at the back which
are actually all had been soaked in
Dental
disinfecting and so actually by the time
we crossed the border I think it was
quite high on the fumes of this
um and then we drove
um from the border to jalalabad and it
was pretty clear very quickly that the
whole thing was quite disastrous because
the roads were being bombed by I the
Afghan Air Force or possibly still
Russians
um but loads of people were fleeing the
city because the majority were trying to
take it and they were firing rockets in
so people were being caught between the
Rockets and the shelling
um and thousands of people were killed
and so it was the first time I'd really
seen like Mass casualties and we were in
a convoy of three ambulances and one of
the ambulances got hit by one of the
Russian bombings
so our ambulance so it pulled straight
off the road to the side
and then they said that they were going
to go back because it was too dangerous
so I said but you're an ambulance you're
supposed to go and collect casualties
and they said no it's too dangerous so
they turned back and I didn't want to go
back because then I was on the outskirts
of Delilah bad so I got them to drop me
a a kind of like
sort of tea place almost like a resting
place for some of them are cheating and
then it was difficult because I wasn't
with any group I was just on my own
there so I had to persuade them to take
me so I think that was a case where I
was just so I never thought about
anything except the story I was
completely determined to get in and see
what was happening and yeah I probably
wanted to be like the first to get in as
well and
um and so I thought I mean now I would
be much
more careful about what I was doing but
then I was just completely I've got to
get in I've got to see what's happening
um
and I did eventually it's changed a lot
and really I think it changed around
first of all around the time of the war
in Iraq because uh we were not able to
get War insurance without going on a
hostile environment course so that's the
first time I did a course and you might
remember people were very worried that
Saddam had the famous chemical weapons
so biological weapons so we would we had
to go on a really bizarre training which
where you were given these little this
pack of little papers so that you could
know what kind of chemical or biological
weapon was being used against you which
didn't seem much used to me given that
you would you know by that time you
would be dead really or about people
so and I remembered the first time I did
the hostile environment course in the
beginning of 2003
um basically learning that everything
I'd been doing for the previous 15 years
was wrong but somehow I'd survived so I
was a little bit perturbed by by this
um and then I think for us certainly at
the Sunday Times things changed a lot
when our colleague Marie Colvin was
killed in Syria in 2011 because that
really brought home the risk
um and uh since then we now have to do
these risk assessments before we travel
which are actually
I hate doing them because you have to do
things like put an exit plan right on it
I mean how do I know an exit plan if I'm
in Afghanistan where there are no pretty
much no diplomats now no only
um Afghan airlines flying in and out
it's very you know if something happens
to you you're pretty you really are on
your own what kind of Exit Plan am I
going to put I don't have somebody
personal who's going to come and extract
me from the mountains impact here or
somewhere so some of this I think it's a
bit of uh an exercise
Executives covering themselves that's
really interesting Christina it's about
that there's a human motivation isn't
there there's a journalistic motivation
um and that affects the way you know we
think about those other mitigating
factors Simon
this notion of how to analyze risk
there's what we do beforehand but
there's actually in the moment and as
it's happening
um Simon how do you work through
particularly when you are in
literally dangerous places
how do you work through in real time
um
well you've got to go with your gut
you've got to go on instinct
uh you're going on
30 years of 30 years of relative
experience and
um in the broadest sense and you rely on
other people around you as well I think
um personally I try not to be surrounded
um only by pessimists or optimists
I need a mix of both
um I definitely need optimists amongst
the people I work with because otherwise
we'd get nothing done but I also need
people like me who stay well what if
this happens what if that happens have
we got a plan for that have we got a
plan D brackets one two if
um the proverbial happens
um in the actual moment
um
I'm slightly embarrassed to say uh
because it might sound a bit ridiculous
out of context but we do sometimes I
sometimes use a sort of scoring system
out of 10
um to indicate how much somebody does or
doesn't want to do things
um and to justify that I would say
um sometimes you can't just rely on
somebody going well you need to be able
to put a figure on it you need a sort of
binary method of measuring how a person
is feeling and I'm talking about one of
my colleagues who may or may not feel
concerned fearful confident or whatever
um about whether we go on a raid with
the El Salvadorian SWAT team in a
particularly dangerous neighborhood
where the last time the police went in
they were met by
automatic weapons fire in a
rocket-propelled grenade so I can't just
drag people into that situation without
discussing it with my small team so
sometimes I'll say how much do you or
don't you want to do this how strongly
do you want to go in there out of 10 How
concerned are you about the people we're
with basically we're talking through the
risk as quickly as we can and we're as
professionally as we can trying to put a
figure
um to give us a binary reference to How
concerned or confident we are and that's
worked reasonably well I'd say we use
percentages as well How likely is it
that we're going to be able to get into
this particular Forest after we've
trekked for three days
to find the endangered primates well we
think we're 60 okay how can we up that
to 70 or 80 these are the sort of
ridiculous TV conversations we have but
Justified I hope by the the end goal
and Simon you've already raised this
issue that um risks lives in different
spaces there's kind of high wire
dramatic risk that we've heard so much
from Christine renew about there's the
more
everyday life risks getting out of bed
one foot in front of the other and
you've also
um uh discussed in some of our
preparation for this conversation we're
having together that it's not actually
the dangerous bits that actually can
cause the really highly risky situations
it's almost the more practical the more
mundane
bits of the job which is not the actual
high wire are we going to get shot in
this situation but it's
it's the more practical things I just
wanted to Simon if you could unravel
that a little bit for us
yeah I think um so I I've talked in the
past and believed quite strongly that
um certainly for what I do
um the greatest danger not lie it lies
not on a front line situation somewhere
because I'm I'm quite rarely in
situations like that it's much more the
vehicle with bald tires no seat belts
and the driver who's still hung over
from the night before
um so those are my particular areas of
concern and I suppose for me very
personally that idea of the the seat
belt is almost quite um Titanic almost
it's it's quite fundamental to my sense
of security I will not travel in a
vehicle almost anywhere now which
doesn't have seat belts in it there is
no there is no excuse for it quite
frankly and just when we were in
um Botswana just now we had a vehicle
with no seat belts in the back but the
the joy of being in a country where such
things are even possible now is you can
always get seat belts welded to the
subframe overnight you can get tires
changed so they're not literally
um literally do not have holes in them
and if the driver is drunk then we can
velcro in the back and sit on and sit on
him has been required on one occasion
and take the wheel ourselves quite
frankly so there's a I suppose that
there's a a certainty about
um danger and risk there and perhaps
almost a confidence about it that means
I am not going to sit next to somebody
who I can smell booze on the breath of
we are going to get him out of that seat
we're going to stop what we're doing and
we're gonna we're gonna reassess but
certainly yes I think for me what I do
wear a seat belt buckling up is
absolutely really key and the people I
work with guys on about it again
um they know it's really fundamental so
my point is really it's it's the basics
and remember you know life is
fundamentally risky it's a miracle any
of us are alive at all we live in a
country where thousands of people are
hospitalized every year because they
have an accident putting their trousers
on in the morning that is not to be
flippant but it is to say that our
existence is fundamentally risky and I
do think every it's up to each
individual to find what their comfort
zone is
um find their tolerance if you like for
risk and then nudge against that I would
suggest because that's where the best
experiences lie and sometimes you've got
to push through that comfort zone a bit
and take slightly more risk but nobody
should be going into situations or
creating situations willingly for
themselves where they're putting
themselves into a state of blind Terror
and panic and PTSD potentially because
of the risks they're experiencing by
choice if you can avoid read
um ludicrous risk then stick with a risk
you're confident and happy with where
the financial or professional
that idea of control what you can
control I think is really fascinating I
love the seat belt metaphor Christina is
there something similar in your mind and
your experience about controlling what
you can control and what might be seen
is almost
a more mundane as you say Simon not to
be flippant but a more mundane way
frankly
um of coming to harm
well I certainly agree about cars
because actually I've lost more friends
in war zones in traffic accidents than
in actually being sold or
um as a direct consequence of the war so
I do agree about that I also something
you mentioned Simon that I think is
really important is instincts and you
know I cannot explain but there have
been situations I've been in that just
seemed wrong
and I'll give an example
during the war in Iraq it would be early
part so I was covering Southern Iraq and
the British troops were
um supposed to be taking bathrobe I was
not embedded with the troops I was what
was called a so-called unilateral so
which basically meant we're almost like
refugees we were driving around in a car
living in a car for weeks and trying to
find what was going on
um and so
the war had just started um Casa had
been taken in the South I think it was
the second day it was a Saturday and so
for me a Sunday paper I needed something
I just joined the Sunday Times
um
um so I with a colleague was driving
towards Basra
um and there was just something on that
road there was no sign of any troops
um there was just something that felt
wrong I just couldn't explain it and in
the end we stopped and and I said
there's just something wrong here we I'm
going to turn back
and my colleague who was less
experienced was a bit baffled I called
the foreign editor and I said look I
don't really know what's happening but
there's no sign of any troops
um
the few people we see look pretty
hostile
um and it just doesn't feel right and he
was really cross and he said to me but
you know I've got what I copy here
saying the US jets are pounding the
bridges of Basra so I said look I'm
sorry I'm at the first Bridge into Basra
nothing's pounding anything I don't know
who's putting that out but it's
absolutely not true there's no signs of
any foreign troops yeah
so I said I'm turning back and he was
annoyed and and then he actually even
said to me are you sure you're on the
right Road there's only one road from it
um and because I just joined the paper
from Sunday's Telegraph and I come
supposedly it's this sort of you know
Brave War correspondent
um so you know there was some pressure
on me to show what I could do and there
I was like the first week literally
saying well I'm turning back
so
so we then drive back to this area where
there was British military police
um maybe half 45 minutes drive back and
they said to me what on Earth were you
guys doing and I said what do you mean
and they said do you not realize you're
driving ahead of the front line so it
was like okay no
um anyway so we stopped there kind of
you know wondering what to do and we had
passed on the road coming as we turned
back a vehicle with TV
um taped on it and so we stopped as
boots them and it was ITN crew
um and I said to them this doesn't feel
right there's no sign of any troops and
it's just very weird down there and
we're turning back and they said oh
we're going to go and see anyway so
while we were then waiting with the
military police they then suddenly got a
message of almost very perturbed and
they said that
um these guys had been attacked And the
reporter had been killed
um so I after that of course felt you
know if that could have been us right
and I cannot to this day explain what it
was that made me feel it was wrong but
you know I'm glad that I turned back and
there have been a number of situations
like that where you just developed
somehow an instinct about things let's
move into the final few minutes of this
absolutely amazing fascinating
conversation with you Simon and
Christina Simon the rest of your life
are you a risk taker on a football field
going to the supermarket are you
constantly uh leaping over turnstiles
and uh making sure that everything you
do is as risky as possible are you at
adrenaline junkie
does it bleed into the rest of your life
the ability to take managed risk in your
professional life
I think it does to a certain degree
um
it's hard for me to fully understand it
though because obviously as I've got
older
um I've become more privileged in every
possible sense and so is it am I taking
as much risk as somebody younger who's
um of different gender trying something
different I doubt it to be honest
um but do I take risks in private life I
suppose I do to a certain degree not I'm
not
um free fall parachuting in my spare
time but what I seek is experiences and
memories and I'm prepared to take
chances for that
um I suppose if I'm if I am a risk taker
then it's primarily professional but
that has definitely
um fed into the rest of my existence as
well
um but uh again I need to know what the
I need to know what the the sort of
reward is rather than just blindly
jumping off a cliff if nobody's looking
if my son is there and I'm trying to
show off to him I might do something
Daft like that but there's got to be a
bit of a reason but deaf definitely I'm
always looking in every aisle of the
supermarket for the new experience if
I'm not jumping over trolleys in the
aisle for whatever reason anyone would
do that come on
Christina I was reading very recently in
the Sunday Times that even on holiday
you managed to take a high degree of
risk even even risks that you maybe
didn't think were coming do tell us
about do you tell us about your most
recent holiday with your husband well I
mean to be fair that was a travel
article I was sent on so it went on this
Cruise of West Africa which was supposed
to be a it was a boutique Cruise in a
very nice boat but or ship I should say
while I was on the plane to Angola to
catch this ship and I must admit Angola
is not a kind of usual place to start a
cruise from
um I'm reading the paper and there was
an article in it saying that there had
been a pirate attack on a ship in a
place called Noir in Congo brazzaville
so I said to my husband he was also
coming on this trip isn't that where
we're going
uh tomorrow on the ship so he looked and
said yeah and then we read further on in
the article and it said that this area
is the most dangerous stretch of sea on
earth now
um and so we were like okay
um and so when we got to the ship in
there was all this razor wire on the
back of this Boutique Cruise
um and uh it was traveling with no
lights at night which was a bit
disconcerting and we had all this sort
of blackout in the restaurant and
everything so
um which wasn't really quite what I
expected of uh cruise and in fact
afterwards when I came back I talked to
somebody who is head of a company that
provides
um or the sort of negotiates the ships
that have been taken by pirates in the
area and he actually couldn't believe
that uh passenger Crews had gone through
that stretch of water
but we survived so that would have been
rather ironic to yes
on a holiday would be rather yeah rather
upsetting to have gone in in in that way
but uh Christina luckily not luckily
you've been here to join us in this
fascinating conversation final question
brief answer would be absolutely lovely
Simon what's the next risky thing you're
gonna do
I don't say cook your lunch or anything
I mean in terms of your professional
life oh professionally oh I hate to say
it's I'm I'm
probably standing on a stage
doing a live stage talk in front of
people is um still that gets the ticker
going
um that feels is it risky it's probably
more scary than risky but um the two are
quite in quite linked together aren't
they so there's a risk involved in that
but I'm excited about it fantastic Simon
and Christina where next for you on the
uh on your professional uh Journey
probably back to Ukraine I think and uh
yeah I mean the one thing I feel about
the war in Ukraine is it is really
sucking the bandwidth from everything
else so there's an awful lot else going
on in the world
like they were in Sudan and what's
happening in Afghanistan and Yemen and
many places that is not getting covered
and that's very frustrating so I try
very hard to to keep going to to those
places too
Simon Christina that has been a
remarkable conversation we've had the
privilege of listening to your stories
thank you for coming on the future verse
podcast please goodness both of you look
after yourself and your loved ones and
your family goodness me I feel I feel
slightly anxious just listening to the
risks you take in your professional life
so thank you so much for joining us for
this conversation and if any of the
issues we've discussed in today's
episode have sparked your interest
please do visit
y-tree.com to find out more about white
tree and the work they are doing to
provide an alternative perspective on
money and life thank you so much for
listening